[Musik]
Dieser Podcast wird Ihnen von der LMU
München präsentiert. Sehnsucht nach der
Einführung. Können Sie mich hören? Okay nein
okay  an der University of
Sydney, aber ich habe den größten Teil meiner akademischen
Karriere dort in Großbritannien verbracht, also entschuldigen Sie
den etwas anderen Titel. Ich werde
im Folgenden erklären, warum das so ist,
also ist dies die Struktur dessen, was ich tun
werde  sprechen Sie darüber, ich werde
Nachhaltigkeit als Konzept untersuchen. sprechen Sie
darüber, wie es auf verschiedene
Themen in der Bioethik angewendet werden könnte. schauen Sie sich einige
Einwände an. Zweifellos werden Sie auf
einige andere stoßen, und wir können einige
Diskussionen führen
, wie Yun sagte  Mein Hauptaugenmerk lag in den
letzten über 15 Jahren darauf, zu
artikulieren und zu erforschen, was wir meinen, wenn
wir über Ethik der öffentlichen Gesundheit sprechen, und im
Grunde war mein Ansatz, mich auf das
zu konzentrieren, was ich eine kleine Ethik nenne,
und nicht auf eine KI-Ethik  also ich denke
viel ethik besonders in bioe  Ethik,
bei der es eine Wechselbeziehung zwischen dem
Nachdenken über Bioethik und dem Zusammenbruch
in medizinische Ethik gibt, liegt der Schwerpunkt auf
den Beziehungen zwischen Individuen, also
einzelnen Patienten und Ärzten,
und ich bin daran interessiert, darüber nachzudenken,
welchen Unterschied es macht, wenn es überhaupt einen Unterschied macht, wenn man
über Ethik in Bezug auf Gruppen und
Gesellschaften nachdenkt  Bevölkerungen, Gesellschaften,
Gemeinschaften und nicht nur Einzelpersonen,
und eines der Projekte, an denen ich beteiligt war,
versucht,
verschiedene, wie ich es nenne, sozial eingebettete
Konzepte zu untersuchen, also sind dies Konzepte wie
Solidarität und Gegenseitigkeit, Gemeinschaft und
Vertrauen, und der Gedanke ist, dass es
das nicht gibt
Im Bereich der Bioethik wurde viel an diesen Konzepten gearbeitet,
daher denke ich, dass wir nicht
nur über
Beziehungen zwischen Individuen
nachdenken müssen, sondern auch über größere Gruppen nachdenken müssen, sondern wir
müssen auch unser philosophisches
Vokabular um die Art von Konzepten und die Art
von Werten erweitern  Es könnte wichtig sein
, über Probleme und viele davon nachzudenken
Konzepte sind meiner Meinung nach besonders
interessant, weil es sich um dicke moralische
Konzepte handelt, die also sowohl eine deskriptive
als auch eine normative Komponente haben, und das
unterscheidet sie deutlich
von anderen Arten von Konzepten,
die
seit dem Wechsel zu Bioethik gut diskutiert wurden  Australien
Vor zweieinhalb Jahren interessierte ich mich sehr dafür
, über indigene Ethik nachzudenken und
welchen Unterschied das machen könnte, um
unser Vokabular über Ethik zu erweitern, also
in einem australischen Kontext, wo die
Engländer 1788 ankamen und sofort
begannen, die lokale Bevölkerung auszurotten
Tradition, die sich
seit langem fortsetzt, und ich
interessiere mich besonders dafür, darüber nachzudenken,
was Auto- und
Kurzvorstellungen darüber machen, wie ihre
Gesellschaften aufgebaut sind, wie sie über Ethik denken,
worauf wir uns stützen können  und füllen Sie
die westliche Tradition aus, um
über ethische Fragen nachzudenken, und es gibt viele
Arten von Elementen  Dazu gehören Ideen
über das Teilen von Ressourcen, die nur der
natürliche Ausgangspunkt sind, anstatt
über Eigentum nachzudenken und
über den Besitz verschiedener Arten von Substanzen nachzudenken,
und da es Ihre direkten
Ressourcen gibt, gibt es eine unmittelbare Vorstellung
davon, dass Ressourcen gemeinsam sind,
die mit dem Nachdenken über die
Beziehung verbunden ist  zwischen Mensch und Land
als etwas, das besonders
wichtig ist,
und es gibt auch dieses Konzept der
Nachhaltigkeit, über das ich heute hauptsächlich
sprechen werde, hat
jemand den Film Umarmung der
Schlange gesehen, kein bester Film, den ich gesehen habe
Ich habe mir in den letzten 18 Monaten viele
Filme angesehen, also ist dies ein Film, der
von einem kolumbianischen Regisseur produziert wurde und auf zwei
Begegnungen zwischen Anthropologen
basiert, darunter einem Deutschen,
und er basiert ungefähr auf
historischen Fällen, aber es geht um a
Konfrontation zwischen Anthropologen
und indigenen Denkweisen und der
Film veranschaulicht sehr schön, was
d  Es könnte einen Unterschied machen, tatsächlich
über indigenere Ideen nachzudenken,
zum Beispiel in diesem Fall über den
Amazonas und die Fischbestände und wie es verschiedene Tabus gibt,
wie z  werden geteilt, wenn wir also
in traditioneller englisch-
westlicher Weise über die Ressourcen nachdenken, die
Fische zum Fangen und Verkaufen da sind, ziehen Sie
als Handelsunternehmen Vorteile daraus,
während Sie an
Fischbestände in einem Fluss denken, in dem Fische
im Laufe des  Jahr
flussauf- und flussabwärts wandern könnte, hat Ihr
Verbrauch dieser Ressourcen
Auswirkungen auf Ihre Nachbarstämme,
und es könnten Gruppen sein, die eine
andere Sprache sprechen, aber es gibt verschiedene
Arten von sozialen Praktiken
, die eingeführt werden, um sicherzustellen, dass dies der Fall ist
Arten von Ressourcen wie Nahrung werden
auf irgendeine Weise zwischen
verschiedenen Arten von Gemeinschaften geteilt, so der
ursprüngliche Titel  Ich habe
ökologische Ethik erwähnt, und
hier werde ich letztendlich hingehen, aber das ist
eher ein Fünfjahresprojekt als etwas,
worüber man in 40 Minuten
sprechen kann, also habe ich beschlossen, es einzugrenzen und über Nachhaltigkeit als solches zu sprechen  ein
Element hier, aber nur für den Fall
, dass es jemanden gibt, der nicht an Nachhaltigkeit interessiert ist,
aber nur kommt, um etwas
über ökologische Ethik zu hören, dies ist die
Folie für Sie, und was ich hier stelle,
sind eine Reihe von Fragen, die uns meiner Meinung nach
die Gelegenheit geben, dies noch einmal zu tun
über Ethik im Allgemeinen nachzudenken und vielleicht
das Vokabular zu erweitern,
also teilweise
wieder durch meine Erfahrung, nach
Australien zu gehen und über die
Unzulänglichkeiten in meinem eigenen Ansatz
nachzudenken, über die Ethik der öffentlichen Gesundheit in
den letzten 15 Jahren
nachzudenken  Denken Sie jetzt über die Ethik der öffentlichen Gesundheit nach.
Ich denke, meine eigene Arbeit war
zu sehr damit beschäftigt, nur über
Menschen nachzudenken, und was mich jetzt interessiert
, ist, herauszufinden, welche Unterschiede es gibt
Es macht Sinn, über ganze Arten von
Ökosystemen nachzudenken, können wir darüber nachdenken,
dass sie einen Wert haben, und was bedeutet das
für das Nachdenken über ethische
Praktiken im Allgemeinen, und es gibt eine
ganze Reihe von Themen, über die wir sprechen können,
denke ich, sicherlich  Ich möchte in
den nächsten Jahren erforschen, welche
Arten von Dingen einen moralischen Wert haben. Sie
wissen, wenn wir uns die Art von
Traditionen und Moraltheorien ansehen, in denen
wir zwischen Personen und
Dingen unterscheiden und Personen Dinge von
Wert sind und Dinge nur solche Dinge sind  wir
besitzen oder wir brechen auseinander oder wir verschenken
an andere Leute oder wir haben verschiedene Arten
von extrinsischen instrumentellen Beziehungen
mit nur Personen auf dieser Art von
Konto, die einen inneren Wert haben, also
ist es wahr, dass das genug ist, um
all die verschiedenen Dinge zu erfassen
die einen Wert haben, also stellt sich die Frage,
was als Person zählt, denn
das ist der Wertmarker, und ich denke,
im Hintergrund steht hier die Annahme,
dass all die moralisch v  Wertvolle Dinge auf
der Welt sind gleich wertvoll. Wenn ich
also einigen meiner Kollegen sage, bin ich daran
interessiert, darüber nachzudenken,
welchen Wert wir ökologischen
Systemen oder Landschaften usw. beimessen, und sie
kommen sehr oft mit mir zu mir zurück
Fragen wie „Oh, Sie wollen also
Moskitos Rechte zuschreiben oder
so“, und diese Art von Fragen setzen
voraus, dass wir daran interessiert sind
, all die Dinge herauszusuchen, die einen
Wert haben, und die Annahme ist, dass jedes
einzelne dieser Dinge den gleichen
Wert hat und  Ich verstehe nicht, warum wir
Dinge so angehen müssen, dass
es alle möglichen Dinge geben kann, die einen Wert haben,
und es könnten Dinge sein, die wir nicht
wirklich in Kombinationen kombinieren können, und
es gibt keinen Grund zu der Annahme, dass jedes
einzelne Ding das ist  moralisch wertvoll ist
gleich wertvoll, also wenn Sie wegen
ökologischer Ethik hier sind, tut mir leid, das
ist Ihre Folie, okay, also werde
ich mich auf Nachhaltigkeit konzentrieren und
einige
der Unterschiede durchgehen  Mieten Sie Definitionen und die
Literatur und schlagen Sie vor, warum es
in vielen von ihnen einige Probleme gibt, und schlagen Sie dann
eine bestimmte Art von Darstellung vor,
es ist keine sehr sprechende Definition, und
schlagen Sie dann vor, wie dieses Konzept
in Bezug auf die Anwendung
auf einige Beispiele funktionieren könnte  Daher konzentriere ich mich hier
sehr darauf, über die
Armut der Werte nachzudenken, die
in den meisten Darstellungen der Bioethik artikuliert werden. Daher
erscheint es mir seltsam, dass Bioethik per
Definition bio bedeutet, dass das Leben so all die
Ethik, die das Leben abdeckt, warum wird diese so
wenig diskutiert
Denken Sie natürlich an Nachhaltigkeit meiner Meinung nach,
jedenfalls scheint es, als wäre dies ein
Konzept, von dem Sie erwarten würden, dass es
einbezogen wird, also gab es einige
Diskussionen, aber es ist ziemlich begrenzt, und wir
können die Frage stellen, warum, und ich denke, es
kommt vor  bis hin zu einer Dominanz einer
bestimmten Reihe von Annahmen darüber, wie
wir über Ethik denken sollten, also können Sie
mich später danach fragen, wenn Sie möchten,
aber dies war Gegenstand von Vorabentscheidungen  Eine interessante
Arbeit von mir in Bezug auf die Kritik, dass
die Art der Konzentration darauf, nur über
die Beziehungen zwischen Individuen nachzudenken,
und die Konzentration auf eine sehr begrenzte Reihe von
Werten, die normalerweise um eine sehr
enge und bestimmte Konzeption von
Autonomie herum aufgebaut sind, im Grunde genommen eine Art
Freiheit ist  Ich denke, wir können eine Reihe von
Fragen stellen, die ich nicht alle genau beantworten werde,
aber ich hoffe, dass das, was
ich sagen werde, eine Art von Antworten zulässt, die darauf
hindeuten,
diese Fragen zu beantworten
Nützliches Konzept Ich denke,
welche Art von Verpflichtungen folgen und wie
es sich mit anderen Werten verbindet.
Was passiert also normalerweise, wenn jemand
für ein anderes Konzept argumentiert,
das nicht auf der Liste der Werte oder
Prinzipien steht, die Sie in der
Bioethik artikuliert sehen  bleibt einfach auf der Liste hängen,
und ich denke, wir müssen darauf achten, das
nicht zu tun, damit Sie die ganze Zeit
Dinge sehen, wie Sie mit den vollständigen
Prinzipien beginnen und dann
Soli hinzufügen  Mut vielleicht und Sie fügen Vertrauen hinzu,
aber es ist für mich nicht offensichtlich, dass
diese von gleicher Gewichtung oder gleicher Art von
Werten sind, also stellt sich die Frage, wie
Kombinationen gemacht werden, sogar eine
Nachhaltigkeit,
etwas, das ein nützliches Konzept ist, aber
nicht unbedingt etwas sein
wird  ist für jedes einzelne
in der Bioethik zu diskutierende Beispiel relevant, also können wir damit
beginnen, eine Reihe
allgemeiner Fragen darüber zu stellen, was eigentlich
Nachhaltigkeit ist
Theoretisiert ist es ein sehr
vages Konzept, das auf alle
möglichen Arten verwendet wird. Jetzt sind viele der
Berichte in erster Linie beschreibend, aber
vermutlich
interessiert uns Nachhaltigkeit deshalb, weil
es dort normalerweise auch eine normative Dimension gibt
, wo Menschen über
Nachhaltigkeit sprechen  darüber zu reden,
als ob es eine gute Sache wäre, also ist es
möglich, Nachhaltigkeit
als etwas zu denken  Das ist manchmal eine
schlechte Sache, denke ich, wenn man erst einmal
darüber nachdenkt, ist es schwer
, sich Beispiele zu denken, wo das der
Fall ist, aber vielleicht gibt es einige, also ist
Vertrauen ein weiteres interessantes Konzept, da
man oberflächlich denken könnte, dass
Vertrauen immer ein ist  Gute Sache,
aber wenn Sie jemandem vertrauen
, der Sie missbraucht, dann ist das eindeutig ein
Fall, in dem es keine gute Sache ist, also muss noch etwas
Arbeit geleistet werden, um diese Art von
Problem zu untersuchen, aber ich denke, ein sehr guter
Anfang, wenn es darum geht, über Nachhaltigkeit nachzudenken,
ist mit  Der äußerst einflussreiche Bericht der Brundtland-Kommission stellt
fest, dass
dies ein Konzept der nachhaltigen
Entwicklung ist, nicht die Nachhaltigkeit selbst,
aber ich denke, wir können es in ein
Nachhaltigkeitskonto umwandeln, damit die nachhaltige
Entwicklung die Bedürfnisse der Gegenwart erfüllt,
ohne die
Fähigkeit zukünftiger Generationen zu gefährden, ihre eigenen zu befriedigen
Bedürfnisse und wir können am Ende eine
Art Konto wie das haben, das ich hier habe,
also erfordert Nachhaltigkeit das heute  y
diese werden nicht so priorisiert,
dass künftige Bedürfnisse nicht erfüllt werden,
also ist das eine Art grober Anhaltspunkt dafür,
worüber wir in Bezug auf Nachhaltigkeit sprechen,
aber interessant ist,
dass es seit 1987 eine Reihe
von Versuchen gab, es zu versuchen  und sagen Sie entweder
genauer, was das Konzept bedeutet, oder
bieten Sie alternative Erklärungen an, und eines
der interessanten Dinge, die ich denke, ist,
dass es in der Diskussion darum geht
, eine Beschreibung des Konzepts der
Nachhaltigkeit zu liefern, aber sehr oft scheint es nicht
das Konzept selbst zu sein, das die Leute zu wollen scheinen
Wenn man es artikuliert, scheint es eine ganze
Perspektive auf die Dinge zu sein, eine Art zu leben,
fast eher als ein Konzept selbst
im strengeren, philosophischeren Sinne, also
bekommt man Ideen wie diese, und
vermutlich ist die Idee, dass Nachhaltigkeit
versucht, Kompromisse einzugehen und
verschiedene Elemente abzuwägen  gegeneinander, so dass
die Wirtschaft die Umwelt ausgleicht, also ist
jeder dieser Gedanken vermutlich
wichtig und wir müssen t ausgleichen  sich
gegeneinander zu wehren, also sich nur auf
eine zu konzentrieren, wird nicht die Antwort sein, also ist seine
Nachhaltigkeit eine Art Balance-
Idee, oder man bekommt Farbe heraus, aber man
bekommt Ideen wie diese, wieder andere Art
von Grafiken für fliegende Untertassen, und hier
gibt es eine ausdrückliche Verpflichtung  zu dem
Gedanken, dass eine Art des
Nachdenkens darüber, wie diese verschiedenen
Elemente gegeneinander abgewogen werden,
Ihnen ein Engagement für Umweltgerechtigkeit verleiht,
dann gibt es Leute, die
einigen dieser Berichte kritisch gegenüberstehen, und sie, also
Farley und Smith, kommen auf diese Idee  Idee
über Neo-Nachhaltigkeit Die Fähigkeit
einer Aktivität, ein System aufrechtzuerhalten, indem
sie seine Qualität verbessert und
innerhalb seiner Grenzen arbeitet, und sie Der Grund
für die Entwicklung von Neo-Nachhaltigkeit ist
offensichtlich, dass Nachhaltigkeit zu vage ist,
aber auch hier, sobald wir anfangen, uns
Gedanken über Regeln zu machen, gibt es eine  Idee ist
mehr als nur ein Konzept Sie wissen, dass
dies ein Bekenntnis zu einer bestimmten Art von
Lebensstil ist,
vielleicht entweder eine Person  Als Verbündeter oder als
Gesellschaft kommen wir zu diesen sechs Wurzeln der
Nachhaltigkeit zurück, wenn Sie
an einem Konzept interessiert sind, wie
beziehen sich diese Wurzeln auf ein Konzept, sind
sie notwendige Voraussetzungen für
Nachhaltigkeit?
Diese waren
offensichtlich, aber nicht alle
zählen nicht als Nachhaltigkeit, was
tatsächlich vor sich geht, und wir haben einige der
gleichen Dinge wieder in sechs
Definitionen von Nachhaltigkeit wiedergespiegelt.
Dies scheint ein
Problem zu sein, wenn Sie es versuchen  artikulieren,
was ein Konzept ist, indem Sie genau das Konzept verwenden
, das Sie innerhalb der Definitionen selbst zu artikulieren versuchen,
also
sprechen wir über Nachhaltigkeit, bla, bla, bla,
wie hilft uns das dabei, darüber nachzudenken,
was Nachhaltigkeit eigentlich ist,
oder Sie können es negativ definieren  Eine
Praxisbeziehung oder Institution ist also
nicht nachhaltig, wenn sie die
sozialen, wirtschaftlichen oder ökologischen
Bedingungen untergräbt, also ist es eine Art Versuch, zu
sagen, wo Nachhaltigkeit ist  Es fehlt,
entschuldigen Sie, eine Sache, die dies aufwirft, ist, darüber
nachzudenken, was Nachhaltigkeit
nicht ist, nämlich keine Erhaltung, denn
einige der Dinge, die wir tatsächlich
über Nachhaltigkeit nachdenken, können
sich im Laufe der Zeit ändern, also
wenn Sie an ökologisch denken
Systeme ändern sich im Laufe der Zeit, aber wir
könnten sie
in dieser Zeit immer noch als nachhaltig betrachten, also geht es nicht
darum, Umgebungen
in das Äquivalent eines Museums zu bringen, okay, also wenn
ich darüber nachdenke,
mich von diesen bestimmten Definitionen zu entfernen, komme
ich auf einen Vorschlag zurück  In einer Minute dazu, wie
wir meiner Meinung nach unser Ausgangspunkt sein sollten
, wenn wir über Nachhaltigkeit nachdenken
, können wir diese Art von Fragen stellen.
Ist Nachhaltigkeit an sich
wertvoll
?
Dass Nachhaltigkeit etwas an sich Gutes ist
, ist klar, dass wir nicht nachhaltig sein
wollen  In allem sprechen wir
über bestimmte Arten von Entitäten, und
wenn ja, welche sind das, wie wählen wir
aus, was relevant ist, und ich möchte mich
auf eine bestimmte Art von Gut konzentrieren, da
es sich um die Art von Dingen handelt, über die wir
nachdenken sollten  Als
Schlüsselparadigma-Dachbodenbeispiele dafür, was wir
in Bezug auf Nachhaltigkeit für wertvoll halten sollten
, also wo bleibt uns das alles
? Hoffentlich hinterlässt mein kurzer Rundgang durch
diese verschiedenen Arten von Konten bei
Ihnen den Eindruck, dass
hier tatsächlich eine Menge Unklarheiten bestehen
Es gibt Menschen, die sich dem
Konzept aus unterschiedlichen Richtungen nähern,
ich denke, sie gehen bereits
von einem sehr starken normativen Engagement aus
und sie interessieren sich eher für Nachhaltigkeit
als Teil eines Lebensstils als
speziell für das Konzept der
Nachhaltigkeit selbst.  Um
zu Fragen zu kommen, die damit zusammenhängen, was
wir tun sollten, wenn
wir konzeptionelle Analysen durchführen, möchte ich nicht
dafür argumentieren  notwendiger und
hinreichender Bedingungen für das Konzept der
Nachhaltigkeitsholding, aber ich denke, wir
können uns eine ungefähre Vorstellung
davon machen, was Nachhaltigkeit ist, wenn wir
über all diese verschiedenen Arten von
Definitionen nachdenken, und das geht wirklich
auf den Ausgangspunkt zurück
Mit der Brundtland-Kommission ist
Nachhaltigkeit also ungefähr eine Verpflichtung
zu einer bestimmten Art von Gerechtigkeit, also die Gewährleistung
der gerechten Verteilung einer bestimmten Art
von Gut durch die Erhaltung dieses
Gutes über die Zeit,
okay, also müssen wir das dann irgendwie
aufschlüsseln  und denken Sie darüber nach, wie diese
Dinge gelten, und einige der relevanten
Überlegungen könnten sein, dass wir
über ein Gut sprechen, das knapp ist und
positiv zum
Wohlergehen beitragen sollte, das Wohlergehen ist, nicht unbedingt
nur das menschliche Wohlergehen,
also ist das Wohlergehen in breiten
ökologischen Begriffen zu sehen und  Wir müssen
viel Arbeit leisten, um tatsächlich zu spezifizieren, wer die
relevanten Parteien sind, und wieder
über ökologische Ethik nachdenken, anstatt über ökologische Ethik nachzudenken
Nachhaltigkeit als Teil dessen,
was Teil des Projekts wäre, welche Art
von Dingen relevant sind, welche Arten von
Dingen wertvoll wären, die
Teil dieses Projekts wären,
also andere Dinge, die man wissen sollte, wie ich bereits erwähnt habe. Ich
denke, Nachhaltigkeit muss ein
normatives Konzept sein, oder?
Ich denke, es kommt darauf an,
wovon wir sprechen, wenn wir uns auf
Waren konzentrieren, dann könnten bestimmte Arten von Waren
die Art von Dingen sein,
zu deren Erhalt wir verpflichtet sind, also
bin ich mir sicher, dass Sie den magischen Haferbreitopf haben  alle sehr
vertraut mit Grimms Märchen, als
meine Kinder klein waren, das ist die Geschichte, die
ich immer und immer wieder lesen musste, also habe
ich diese sich wiederholende Sache eingebaut
, aber kennt jeder die Geschichte
Magic Purge Porridge Pot Nein, das ist so
Die Idee, dass Sie einen Topf haben,
der endlose Mengen an Brei produziert.
Wenn Sie also das Glück haben, einen solchen Topf zu haben, haben
Sie tatsächlich keine begrenzte
Ressource.
In diesem Fall ist der gute Brei in diesem Fall nicht
etwas  g, dass man über
Nachhaltigkeit in der Zukunft nachdenken muss, weil
man unendlich viel davon hat, also sind
bestimmte Arten von Gütern so, dass
manchmal Leute über bestimmte
Arten von öffentlichen Gütern als Dinge sprechen
, die frei verfügbar sind, wie
zum Beispiel saubere Luft  Es wird davon
ausgegangen, dass es sich um ein öffentliches Gut handelt, und dass
Ihr K'en'dl-Luftverbrauch
keine Auswirkungen auf alle
anderen haben wird. Natürlich gibt es
Eingriffe in die Gesellschaft
, die zu einer schlechten Luftqualität führen, und das
hat sie  Auswirkungen auf die Menschen, aber im Allgemeinen sind
öffentliche Güter eine bestimmte
Art von Gut und ein magischer
Breitopf  bestimmte Arten von Waren, bei denen Ihr
Konsum Auswirkungen auf
andere Menschen hat,
also werde ich mit einem Beispiel für
antimikrobielle Resistenz beginnen und dies
argumentieren  gibt es hier bestimmte Arten von Gütern
, die gute Beispiele für Ressourcen sind,
die verbraucht werden und die daher
Auswirkungen auf andere Menschen in der
Zukunft haben, und wir müssen darüber nachdenken
und das berücksichtigen, und Arzneimittel, bei
denen sich Antibiotikaresistenzen entwickeln, sind
die Arten von Gütern  wo
wir Ideen über Nachhaltigkeit tatsächlich brauchen oder können, um
einen Grund dafür zu liefern, warum
wir Ihre Praktiken jetzt ändern müssen,
um diese Waren in Zukunft für andere zu erhalten,
also ein bisschen Fachjargon, also ist
antimikrobielle Resistenz eine breite
Kategorie von Problemen im Zusammenhang mit der
Entwicklung  Resistenz gegen eine Reihe
verschiedener Medikamente ist das beste Beispiel, um
sich auf Antibiotika zu konzentrieren, und die Tatsache, dass
seit der Entwicklung von Antibiotika
Resistenzen zunehmen, so dass es
verschiedene Probleme in Bezug auf die
Krankenhausbehandlung in einem klinischen Umfeld gibt,
in dem Sie verschiedene Infektionen haben, die
jetzt resistent sind  zu vielen der Medikamente
, die wir haben, und obwohl es
offiziell nicht oft kommt  Innerhalb
der AMR-Klammer sollte man meiner
Meinung nach über die Entwicklungen bei der
Tuberkulose nachdenken und die Tatsache, dass viele
der Tuberkulose-Medikamente zunehmend
therapieresistent werden und dies nur
eine Tatsache der Biologie ist, wie sich
Bakterien hier wieder auf
Antibiotika konzentrieren  Im Gegensatz zu AMR im Allgemeinen ist
dies einfach unvermeidlich, dass dies
so oft passieren wird. Die Lösung, die
für
Probleme im Zusammenhang mit
Antibiotikaresistenzen vorgeschlagen wird, ist, dass wir einige neue
Medikamente entwickeln, die für kurze Zeit helfen können,
aber im Laufe der Zeit ist
diese Resistenz unvermeidlich  wird sich auch zu diesen
Medikamenten entwickeln Bach-Bakterien sind schlau,
sie können reagieren und sich entwickeln und
so weiter, aber diese Resistenz ist nicht nur
ein biologisches Merkmal, und es gibt
verschiedene menschliche Eingriffe, die
den Prozess beschleunigt haben, also tragen wir aktiv
dazu bei  Schnelligkeit der
Entwicklung von Resistenzen und es gibt
Beispiele für den unangemessenen Einsatz von
Antibiotika  Entive Chirurgie zum Beispiel, wo
sie über einen längeren Zeitraum verabreicht werden
und wirklich notwendig sind, ihre verschiedenen
Arten von kommerziellen Elementen hier, die
mit der Verwendung bestimmter Antibiotika in der
Landwirtschaft zu tun haben, also bin ich sicher, dass die meisten von Ihnen
Fleischesser sind, wenn Sie
Wenn Sie Fleischesser sind, dann kann Ihr Fleisch etwas billiger sein, wenn
Sie Antibiotika in der Landwirtschaft verwenden, weil
die Tiere schneller wachsen und so weiter.
Innerhalb eines europäischen Kontextes gibt es möglicherweise
Vorschriften, um dies zu verhindern, aber im
globalen Kontext gibt es andere Teile davon
In der Welt, in der dies geschieht, werden
Antibiotika frei verwendet, und das
wird Auswirkungen auf Länder haben, in
denen die Verwendung von
Antibiotika in Lebensmitteln verboten ist,
also gibt es eine Kombination aus landwirtschaftlicher
kommerzieller Verwendung in der Veterinärmedizin,
Zahnmedizin, Medizin usw  sind
weit verbreitete Dinge, und je mehr
Sie sie verwenden, desto mehr beschleunigen Sie
die Entwicklung von Resistenzen und
um dies nur in irgendeiner Weise zu
relativieren, und diese Figur  Es wurde
bestritten, aber der O'Neill-Bericht aus
Großbritannien argumentiert, dass die
Auswirkungen der wachsenden antimikrobiellen
Resistenz in der Zukunft enorm
sein werden, also können Sie sehen, dass O'Neill
eigentlich ein Ökonom ist, also muss
alles auf US-Dollar reduziert werden  Aber Sie
können auch die Auswirkungen in Bezug auf
die Anzahl der Menschen sehen, die
voraussichtlich sterben werden, ein
so bedeutendes Problem, und natürlich werden die
Auswirkungen nicht überall
auf der Welt gleich sein, und das
hängt teilweise mit den unterschiedlichen
Praktiken zusammen  Bezug auf den Einsatz von Antibiotika
in verschiedenen Ländern, aber im Allgemeinen geht
der Trend zu immer größeren
Resistenzen, auch wenn es
Unterschiede zwischen bestimmten Ländern geben kann,
wenn Sie sich Europa ansehen, zum Beispiel gibt
es sehr signifikante Unterschiede zwischen
Nordeuropa und Südeuropa, und
diese beziehen sich auf die Kultur  Praktiken in
Bezug darauf, wie einfach es ist, wie
akzeptabel es ist, die Erwartung in
Bezug auf die Einnahme von Antibiotika
sogar für condi  wo es
unangemessen ist, wie bei Erkältungen und Grippe
und so weiter. Wenn Sie also einen Virus haben, werden
Antibiotika nichts nützen,
und in vielen Ländern werden
Ihnen die Ärzte das sagen, und sie werden
es Ihnen in anderen Ländern verweigern
Zugang zu ihnen haben,
einiges hat mit der Kultur zu tun, anderes hat mit Gesundheitssystemen zu tun.
Wenn Sie also ein
Gesundheitssystem haben, in dem der Arzt
tatsächlich eine finanzielle Belohnung für die
Bereitstellung von Medikamenten erhält, überrascht es Sie, dass
Sie höhere Konsumraten sehen  und
dann höhere Resistenzraten
, die in Ordnung sind, in Ordnung, also gibt es alle
möglichen Probleme in Bezug auf MMR, auf die
ich nicht eingehen werde, aber eines der
interessantesten ist, über die
Auswirkungen auf zukünftige Generationen nachzudenken,
sodass unser Konsum jetzt Konsequenzen hat
Für andere können wir jetzt darüber nachdenken,
das Konzept der Nachhaltigkeit zu verwenden,
um etwas darüber zu sagen, also sind sie sehr
ähnlich mit all den verschiedenen
Argumenten, die Sie in Bezug darauf vorbringen können
Dies und einige von ihnen sind
eigennützig und aufsichtsrechtlich, also ist es
in Ihrem individuellen Interesse,
weniger Antibiotika zu verwenden, aber ich wollte mich darauf
konzentrieren, über Nachhaltigkeit nachzudenken
, da dies wirklich ein
Argument ist, um zu veranschaulichen, wie
Nachhaltigkeit einen Unterschied machen kann
Diese spezielle
bioethische Frage, also haben diejenigen in der
Zukunft einen Anspruch, dass wir verpflichtet sind
, Antibiotika für die Verwendung in der Zukunft aufrechtzuerhalten, sagte
ich, ja, und ich denke,
das macht es zu einem interessanten Fall, dass
der Fall geklärt werden muss  ist,
dass wenn wir an Gerechtigkeit denken,
das Nachdenken über Gerechtigkeit und
Verteilungen zu einem bestimmten
Zeitpunkt nachlässt und dies erfordert, dass wir nicht nur
über Verteilungen zum Zeitpunkt t1
nachdenken, sondern auch darüber nachdenken, welche Auswirkungen
dies in Bezug auf sie haben könnte
Zukunft Wenn wir also Antibiotika
als eine bestimmte Art von Gut betrachten, habe
ich argumentiert, dass sie kein öffentliches Gut sind,
sondern die Art von Gut, die t  Das
Konzert mehr Konsum bedeutet jetzt, dass
in Zukunft weniger verfügbar ist,
also sind sie ein endliches Gut, es ist kein
magischer Breitopf. Dies nenne ich
hier
Bankwaren, um die Metapher einer Bank zu verwenden
dagegen ausgeben, dass es
vor Ende des Monats verschwinden wird,
bevor Ihr nächster Gehaltsscheck eintrifft.
Das ist die Natur dieser
Art von Waren, und Antibiotika sind
genau die gleichen, je mehr wir
sie jetzt verwenden, desto weniger werden sie in Zukunft verfügbar
sein  und warum dies wichtig
ist, ist, dass, wenn wir sie jetzt
für relativ triviale
Zwecke verwenden, sie möglicherweise unnötig sind
und das bedeutet, dass sie
in Zukunft nicht verfügbar sind, wo sie
wirklich entscheidend sein könnten, um
jemandes Leben zu retten  dann ist das nicht ein
ernstes Problem mit den Ideen, die mit Gerechtigkeit zu tun haben
? Nehmen wir also wieder an, dass
wir in einem Land leben, in
dem Antibiotika in der
Landwirtschaft verwendet werden  Bist du froh, dass
du 10 Cent pro Kilo weniger für
dein Fleisch bezahlst und das bedeutet, dass deine Enkelkinder sterben werden, weil
sie keine
Antibiotika zur Verfügung haben, weißt du, wenn
wir das gleiche Medikament haben, das wir auf
diese verschiedenen Arten verwenden könnten, das sind die Arten
Es ist ein leicht philosophisches Beispiel,
eher ein Beispiel aus der realen Welt, aber die Idee
ist, dass dies die Art von Entscheidungen sind, denen
wir uns
jetzt stellen müssen. Es ist kein Argument dafür, dass die
Menschen in der Zukunft wertvoller
sind als die Menschen jetzt, aber  Es ist viel wichtiger, darüber
nachzudenken, wie das Gleichgewicht zwischen
Schaden und Nutzen im Leben gerettet werden
könnte, als
über die relativ geringen
Unterschiede in der Menge nachzudenken, die Sie
für Fleisch bezahlen, oder um einen Wunsch zu befriedigen, von dem Sie
glauben, dass Sie diese schlimme Erkältung haben und
Als Sie das letzte Mal eine Erkältung
hatten, haben Ihnen die Antibiotika etwas genützt,
deshalb wollen Sie jetzt Antibiotika,
die diese Präferenz befriedigen, ist nicht
gleichbedeutend damit, jemandem das Leben in der Zukunft zu retten,
ok  y und ich wollte nur sagen, dass dies nicht
nur ein Argument über antimikrobielle
Resistenz oder Antibiotika ist, wir können darüber
nachdenken, dass Nachhaltigkeit etwas ist, das
relevant ist, wenn wir auch über Gesundheitssysteme nachdenken,
also wenn Sie
an Gesundheitsressourcen und der Konstante interessiert sind
Fokus, dass Politiker
argumentieren müssen, dass die Ressourcen im Gesundheitswesen
begrenzt sind und wir irgendeine Art
von Rationierung haben müssen,
aber das ist es, was sie mit dieser Art
von Idee meinen, eines der Argumente, die
sie zumindest in einigen Fällen verwenden könnten  Kontext ist,
über Nachhaltigkeitsargumente nachzudenken.
Wenn wir also ein Gesundheitssystem mit
verschiedenen Arten von Anforderungen an es aufgebaut haben
, müssen wir möglicherweise
nicht nur ernsthaft über die
Verteilung jetzt nachdenken, sondern auch über
zukünftige Verteilungen, wenn wir
unsere vollständig zerstören  Gesundheitssystem, indem
wir jetzt alles ausgeben, ist das kein Problem, also gibt es viele andere Fälle, in denen wir über
Nachhaltigkeit als etwas nachdenken könnten  Das ist
relevant für Argumente in der Bioethik,
aber ich wollte nur ein wenig
über Gesundheitssysteme sagen, damit Sie
nicht auf die Idee kommen, dass es hier nur um
Antibiotika geht
Klammern Sie könnten andere
Arten von Argumenten haben, um über
Argumente nachzudenken, die in die
gleiche Richtung gehen wie die Nachhaltigkeits-Argumente in
Bezug auf Gegenseitigkeit und Solidarität.
Okay, also traditionelle Einwände gegen die
Idee der Nachhaltigkeit denken Sie
daran, über die Ressourcen nachzudenken, die
wir jetzt haben, und darüber nachzudenken  unsere
Verpflichtung, diese
für die Zukunft zu erhalten Ich werde nur
über zwei Standardeinwände sprechen, einer
stammt von einem Ökonomen und der andere ist
ein eher philosophischer Einwand, so dass es
sehr oft der Fall ist, wenn
Ökonomen über die Bewertung verschiedener
Vorschläge nachdenken  Sie fahren fort, eine
Art Rabatt auf zukünftige Vorteile
oder Schäden anzubieten, also ist der Gedanke, dass für einen
Dollar einen Euro  o
Wenn Sie es jetzt ausgeben, hat es einen unmittelbaren Nutzen, während es weniger Nutzen hat, wenn Sie
es in der Zukunft ausgeben, weil es in
der Zukunft liegt, und wir
können darüber streiten, was die relevante Art
von ermäßigtem Zinssatz sein könnte, also ein
Argument dafür, dass
Nachhaltigkeit nicht so etwas ist  Worauf wir uns
in solchen Kontexten konzentrieren sollten, ist zu
argumentieren, dass wir tatsächlich mehr Nutzen
durch Interventionen jetzt durch
Verteilungen jetzt erhalten, anstatt darüber
nachzudenken, an einigen Ressourcen in
der Zukunft festzuhalten, und ich möchte argumentieren, dass diese
Art von Annahme im Wesentlichen a ist
Merkmal des Modells, das Ökonomen
verwenden, und wo Sie einen zukünftigen
Nutzen haben, ist es immer noch ein Nutzen und Sie geraten
in einige paradoxe Situationen, wenn
Sie dies zu ernst nehmen, also ein Argument
zum Beispiel gegen Impfungen, wo
die Vorteile in 10 Jahren kommen könnten,
weil die  Vorteile sind in 10 Jahren,
wir sollten
diesem Vorteil weniger Wert beimessen, weil er heute nicht mehr
eintritt, also wird es b  Eine systematische
Unterbewertung der Idee der Begnadigung
Ironischerweise könnte es sein, dass Sie
bessere wirtschaftliche Erträge erzielen, wenn Sie darauf warten, dass
Menschen infiziert werden, und sie dann
behandeln, anstatt zu versuchen, diese Interventionen zu verhindern. Daher
denke ich, dass
es sich lohnt, einigen davon ein wenig
skeptisch gegenüberzustehen  Diese diese Modelle, wie ich
hier sage, es könnte für Straßen funktionieren, aber
es ist offensichtlich nicht der Fall, dass es
in Bezug auf Beispiele im Gesundheitswesen funktionieren wird,
und der zweite Einwand
, den viele von Ihnen und dem Publikum mit
philosophischem Hintergrund sicher
haben werden  Ich habe bereits darüber nachgedacht, also
gibt es einen Standardeinwand gegen das Nachdenken
über die Verpflichtungen, die wir gegenüber
zukünftigen Generationen haben, die
von der Arbeit von Derek Parfit sehr beeinflusst werden,
und die Idee dort ist, dass wir
es mit einem Nicht-Identitätsproblem zu tun haben,
also sind wir es nicht
Wenn wir über die Zukunft sprechen, wenn wir jetzt Entscheidungen über
die Zukunft treffen, sprechen wir nicht über
besonders existierende Individuen, die
sie nicht sind  echte Individuen,
sie sind eine Art zukünftige Individuen, die
entstehen werden. Wir wissen nicht,
wer diese Individuen sind, und das
Argument lautet, dass die bloße Tatsache, dass
sie in der Zukunft
existieren, für sie von Vorteil ist, also die Entscheidungen, die wir treffen
machen, um die Ressourcen jetzt zu nutzen, haben nur
Auswirkungen auf die Zukunft
, aber die Auswirkungen auf die
Personen, die diese Personen sind, werden tatsächlich eintreten, also
lautet die Antwort hier, dass
jemand, der nicht als Ergebnis eines
Kindes geboren wurde, das in sechs Generationen stirbt, nicht
geschädigt wird  Das ist also der Puff-en-Non-
Identity-Einwand, aber die Antwort ist, dass
unsere Verpflichtungen gegenüber zukünftigen Personen
als Klasse bestehen, also ist es wahr, dass wir nicht
genau angeben können, wer diese Personen sind,
aber wir wissen das, es sei denn, die Welt
explodiert und alle Menschen werden ausgerottet
oder was auch immer, dass es zukünftige Personen geben wird,
und wir könnten auf die Tatsache setzen,
dass es zukünftige Personen geben wird, wir
können sie nicht benennen, wir können sie nicht identifizieren,
aber wir wissen, dass sie als
Klasse existieren werden  und das könnte ausreichen,
um diese speziellen Einwände zu
umgehen, damit wer auch immer existiert, sein Leben wird besser laufen,
wenn diese Medikamente tatsächlich
in der Zukunft aufrechterhalten werden, und wieder hat es
teilweise mit dieser Vorstellung über die
Unterschiede zwischen den Schäden und den
Vorteilen jetzt im Vergleich zu den Schäden zu tun  und
Vorteile in der Zukunft die
Befriedigung Ihrer schlecht informierten Präferenz,
jetzt unangemessen Antibiotika zu nehmen, ist nicht
von gleichem oder größerem Gewicht
als das Leben von jemandem in der
Zukunft zu retten, selbst wenn wir nicht wissen, wer diese
bestimmten Personen sein werden, so meine
Schlussfolgerungen  Wenn Sie an Nachhaltigkeit denken, müssen
wir noch
etwas an der Verfeinerung und dem
Konzept arbeiten, aber es ist im Wesentlichen etwas
, das mit dem Nachdenken über
Verteilungen und das Nachdenken über Gerechtigkeit zusammenhängt.
Ich habe ein paar Beispiele dafür gegeben, wie
es auf andere Weise angewendet werden könnte  Argumente
über Bioethik, und vielleicht verbindet sich dies
mit einer ganzen Diskussion über
Umweltgerechtigkeit oder einer breiteren
Darstellung  der Gerechtigkeit über engere
Konten hinaus, auf die wir uns
in dieser Art von Diskussionen sehr oft konzentrieren,
also bin ich sicher, dass es viele Dinge zu besprechen gibt,
aber dies ist ein
Thema, bei dem ich nicht so viel mit Bildern in PowerPoint zu tun habe, wie Sie es können
sag aber das ist ein bild von sidney
nur dazu
gibt es in sydney im
moment 38 grad also wo es etwas wärmer ist als
hier